كل يغني على ليلى اوروبا تحدد سعر الخام
الروسي ومسكوت تبدو غير ابها بتلك
القرارات اما كياف فتنتقدها وتعتبرها غير
منصفه دعونا نبدا من موافقتي الدول 27
الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعات
السبع واستراليا على حد اقصى لسعر الخام
الروسي يبلغ 60 دولارا للبرميل الواحد
ابريما الاتفاق بعد ان كان معلقا من قبل
بولندا التي اعطت الضوء الاخضر لهذه الخطه
رغم انها كانت تعتبر انه محدود جدا لكنها
لم تجد مفارا سوى القبول في النهايه روسيا
وعلى لسان المتحدث باسم الكريم
شددت على عدم رضوخها لتحديد سقف لسعر
نفطها وحددت بعدم تزويد الدول التي ستطبق
هذا السقف
سفير وروسيا لدى المنظمات الدوليه في
فيينا ميخائيل اوليانوف قالها ايضا بصريح
العباره اعتبارا من العام الجاري ستعيش
اوروبا بدون النفط الروسي
سفاره روسيا في الولايات المتحده شركه في
هذا الموقف الرسمي الموحد لموسكو رفضه
اعاده صياغه المبادئ الاساسيه للسوق الحره
مؤكده ان الطلب على نفطها سيستمر رغم
القرار الغربي اما الرئيس الاوكراني فولو
دي ميرسيلين سكي فلم يعجبه اساسا ذلك
الرقم المتفق عليه جمله وتفصيلا فهو على
حد تعبيره لا يعكس جديه تخدم الهدف المرجو
لضعاف موسكو وحرمانها من وسائل استمرار
تمويلي عمليتها العسكريه على ارضه
ساره السوشي جيم ديسكو
[موسيقى]
يعني موسكو
يكبح قوتها العسكريه خاصه وان الرقم
المحدد لم يتغير كثيرا فسعره راهنا قبل
دخول الاتفاق حيز التنفيذ غدا يبلغ 65
دولار
اعتبره زلينسكي قرارا مريحا تماما لموازنه
ما اسماها دوله ارهابيه ويبقى الاتفاق
يدججوا ميزانيه موسكو ب 100 مليار دولار
سنويا ستستخدم للحرب وانظمتها وليس انتهاء
انا بزعزعتي ذات الدول التي اتخذت ذلك
القرار غير المشتي
مجلس
الشعب دوري بلس
صحيح ان نزلنسكي وصف القرار الصادر بتحديد
سقف لسعر النفط الروسي بانه ينم عن موقف
ضعيفه لكنه اندريه ماك مدير مكتب رئاسته
في كياف يحاول ان يتفائل ويرى فيه بصيص
امل بان تدمير اقتصاد روسيا مستمر فالقليل
الدائم خير من كثير منقطع وبينما لانه
اوروبا من وطاه اسعار الطاقه وتلجا لخطوات
يراها محللون غير مجديه من قدر الكافي
تراوغ روسيا في البحار وبدات وفقه صحيفه
وكانها كانت تستعد لهذا القرار عبر اسطول
من ناقلات النفط يعرف باسمي اسطول الظل
تحايل على العقوبات والقرارات الدوليه
ووفقا التقارير الغربيه فروسيا اما اشترت
او استاجرت اكثر من 100 كاسحه جليد قادره
على التنقل في البحار المتجمده حول موانئ
البطيق الروسيه لا سيما وان نفطر روسي
للحياه الاقتصادي للبلاد ومفتاح تمويل
للعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا اسطول مظلم
او غير موازن تختلف التسميات لكن فحواها
واحده ايصال النفط للمشتريين في ظل تزايد
العقوبات على روسيا لضمان استمرار تدفق
العائدات ناقلات الظل هي ناقلات عتيقه شبه
مهتعه عمرها غالبا يتراوح بين 12 و15 عاما
هو عمر لا تحدده عاده شركات النفط الكبرى
بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالسلامه تبحر عاده من
دون اي تامين حقيقي
رغم عمرها طويل الا انها سوقها باتت عائشه
وباسعار منافسه ارتفعت بنسبه
37% في الاوانات الاخيره وبغض النظر عن
سرعتها البطيئه لكنها تعتبر ملاذان
لمتابعه التدفقات فهي تباعه بشكل غريب غير
رسمي تماما كما مهمتها نقل النفط ايضا
بطرق ملتويه بعيدا عن الامطار كيف ذلك
ببساطه هي تقوم بتغيير الاعلام التي
تحملها
وتوقف تشغيل اجهزه الارسال او ترسل اشارات
خادعه انما هذا النوع من الاساطير
المشاهدين قبل عشر سنوات لشحن النفط
الايراني بعد ان شددت واشنطن العقوبات على
طهران عام 2012 وزاد الطلب عليها عندما
اعادت اداره ترامب فرض المزيد من العقوبات
روسيا على مر التاريخ صمدت عده مرات في
وجه الصعوبات وستتمكن هذه المره ايضا من
قام بوضع سقف لسعر نفط روسي سيعاني كثيرا
لاننا اغنياء بالموارد الطبيعيه
لكي لا تحدث ازمه اقتصاديه داخل البلاد